digamos que tenemos el número 0.4 008 y
este número se repite una infinidad de
veces que queremos decir con esta con
esta rayita en realidad tenemos 0.4 008
y luego se repite 4 008 y se repite otra
vez 4 008 muy bien y así se sigue
repitiendo una infinidad de veces
entonces la pregunta que te hago es como
podríamos escribir este número como una
suma infinita y una vez que tengas una
respuesta la pregunta es se puede
escribir con una serie geométrica así
que te invito a que hagas una pausa para
que reflexiones sobre este problema y
trates de resolverlo
entonces suponiendo que ya lo hiciste
vamos a ver qué pasa con este número
primero tenemos esta parte de aquí que
lo podemos expresar simplemente como 0.4
008 y luego podemos sumar esta parte de
aquí que éste no es otra cosa más que
0.000 0 4 008 muy bien simplemente
sumamos esta parte de aquí 4 008 pero
con 4 ceros anteriormente a la hora de
sumar estos dos nos da este término
digamos hasta este término rojo muy bien
qué pasa si ahora le sumamos esta parte
azul la parte azul será 0 punto y hay
que agregar 8 ceros
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y luego ponemos 4 008 y
así podemos ir sumando muchos más
términos verdad simplemente al ir
agregando 4 ceros entonces aquí
y un patrón cada término le vamos
agregando cuatro ceros y por supuesto
esto ya está escrito en términos de una
serie verdad
es una serie no es una infinidad de
términos que estamos sumando ahora la
pregunta es será cierto que esto es una
serie geométrica vamos a ver si es
cierto lo que tendríamos entonces es
encontrar una proporción común veamos
por cuánto habría que multiplicar este
término para que podamos obtener este de
este rojo
entonces si nos damos cuenta estamos
recorriendo el punto decimal cuatro
lugares a la izquierda entonces esto es
lo mismo que multiplicar por diez a la
menos cuatro o lo que digamos
multiplicarlo por 0.0001 que es una
diezmilésima verdad vamos a ver qué pasa
de este rojo a este azul por cuánto hay
que multiplicar para obtener este número
pues nuevamente aquí estaría el punto
decimal y hay que recorrer los cuatro
espacios que es lo mismo que
por 10 a la menos cuatro o lo que es lo
mismo 0.001 muy bien entonces como te
das cuenta este número de aquí es
nuestra proporción común de hecho y este
éste esté sumando amarillo lo podemos
escribir como 0.4 0 0 8 por 10 a la
menos 4 elevado a la 0 como escribimos
el término rojo esto es más 0.4 0 0 8 x
10 a la menos 4 elevado a la 1 y el
término azul será ahí vamos a ponerlo en
azul
0.40 08 y aquí multiplicamos por 10 a la
menos 4 pero dos veces verdad primero
una para alcanzar el rojo y luego otra
para para hacerlo el azul y así seguimos
sumando entonces realmente esto es una
serie geométricas y se demás claro que
es una serie geométrica y de hecho la
podemos expresar con la notación usando
la letra griega sigma verdad esto es lo
mismo que la suma desde acá igual a cero
hasta infinito de
0.4 008 que multiplica a 10 a la menos 4
y vamos aumentando cada vez más el
exponente entonces aquí va nuestra acá
muy bien entonces la pregunta aquí bueno
ya ya resolvimos la pregunta de si lo
podemos expresar como una serie y de
hecho vemos que es una serie geométrica
donde la proporción comunes 10 a la
menos 4 la pregunta es bueno y esto
cuánto vale te invito a que hagas una
pausa y utilices todo lo que ya sabemos
sobre series geométricas infinitas para
poner esto como una fracción
así que si ya lo hiciste vamos vamos a
darle rienda a este problema a la
solución del problema y recordemos que
si tenemos una serie geométrica digamos
desde acá igual a cero hasta infinito de
a por el real acá la forma de calcular
esto es simplemente a que es nuestro
término inicial entre uno menos la
proporción común entonces vamos a
utilizarlo en este ejercicio nuestra a
vale 0.4 0 08 y esto lo dividimos lo
dividimos entre 1 - 1 - la proporción
común que son 10 a la menos 40.000 11
diezmilésimos vamos a ver entonces esto
a que será igual bueno uno en
diezmilésimos cuántos son pues son
10.000 diezmilésimos verdad y porque los
expresamos así porque esto de aquí es un
diezmilésimos entonces al expresar lo de
esta forma
un denominador común y se vuelve muy
sencilla esta resta verdad porque
entonces arriba quedará o que dejarlo
con los mismos colores que dará 0.4 008
todo esto dividido entre 10 mil 10.000
decimos menos un 10 milésimo que son 9
mil 999 diezmilésimos muy bien entonces
como como calculamos esta esta fracción
pues esto será igual a 0.4 008 que
multiplica a 10 mil a 10 mil
y esto lo dividimos entre no 9 1999 ok y
esto es muy bonito porque 10.000 por
este número es simplemente recorrer el
punto decimal cuatro lugares a la
derecha y entonces nos queda simplemente
cuatro mil ocho entre
9999 muy bien entonces esto de aquí ya
es digamos la respuesta aunque todavía
podríamos simplificarlo más por ejemplo
en el numerador la suma de sus dígitos
son 4 y 8 que son 12 y es divisible
entre 3 y claramente el de aquí abajo es
divisible entre 3 así que podemos
simplificarlo todavía más por ejemplo si
dividimos 4 mil 84 mil 8 entre 3 nos da
3 por una son 3
y restamos y nos quedan 4
son 3 3 y 4 menos 3 es 1 y bajamos el
cero luego multiplicamos por 3 3 por 3 ó
9 entonces 10 menos 9 nos da 1 bajamos
el otro 0 3 por 3 son 9 10 menos 9 1 y
bajamos el 8 y 3 por 6 son 18 y nos
queda un residuo de 0 entonces el
numerador es 1.336 / dividido entre 9
1999 y aquí bueno yo creo que ya no creo
que sea no se puede simplificar a lo
mejor sí pero bueno yo me quedo ya con
esta respuesta esto fue muy bonito
logramos expresar un decimal periódico
es decir un decimal que se repite una
infinidad de veces no sólo como una
serie geométrica sino que además esto
nos ayudó para expresar lo como una
fracción utilizando la fórmula de la
suma de esta serie